fine I can't see can I borrow your  glasses Shh it's starting also they're  not prescription this winter the quest  for the Super Bowl begins teammates will  come together Fred avenge Grunk death  not dead wrong but yes I'll get us that  trophy this year divisions only pick it  up from water life good thing I've been  watching West world you've got it ten  ninety one for the mind and then a  disturbance call over in the Georgia  Dome too old for this  walk the plank Hopkins the Chiefs are on  the horizon it's broke this is a literal  cliffhanger know who will it be from the  people who brought you the regular  season comes Playoffs the movie we were  supposed to be in that hey down in front